[Música]
Ucrania fue testigo a lo largo de esta
semana de una escalada de bombardeos por
parte de las tropas rusas que han
conseguido afectar buena parte de la
infraestructura ucraniana Como por
ejemplo las vías de comunicación los
hospitales y han dejado sin electricidad
acerca de 10 millones de ciudadanos la
oscuridad y el frío que están viviendo
los ucranianos en este momento Tal
parece que solamente es una breve bocas
de lo que puede ser el invierno en medio
de la guerra la ONU ya expresó su
preocupación por una catástrofe
humanitaria que podría suceder en los
próximos meses ya de hecho comenzaron a
caer las primeras nevadas en Ucrania y
las temperaturas también han bajado
rápidamente normalmente este país debe
soportar inviernos muy fríos y
prolongados mucho más fríos si se
compara con el resto de Europa central
pero para entrar en materia entonces
recordemos algunos de los hechos que
ocurrieron a lo largo de esta semana en
el conflicto en Ucrania en solamente un
día las tropas rusas dispararon cerca de
67 misiles 52 de ellos fueron derribados
por las fuerzas ucranianas de acuerdo a
las autoridades de este país 30 misiles
fueron dirigidos solamente a kiev la
capital del país donde impactaron
diferentes blancos también esta semana
el parlamento europeo declaró a Rusia
como estado promotor del terrorismo con
nuestros invitados vamos a analizar
Entonces cuál es el alcance el alcance
de esta declaración también esta semana
kiev y Moscú se están acusando
mutuamente de diferentes crímenes de
guerra Lo cierto es que las autoridades
ucranianas encontraron cuatro cámaras de
torturas en gerson ciudad que fue
recuperada de manos de las tropas rusas
Asimismo la ONU también comenzó una
investigación para esclarecer la muerte
de un grupo de soldados rusos que se
habían rendido ante las tropas
ucranianas y murieron y otros dos puntos
importantes para destacar a lo largo de
esta semana el anuncio del presidente de
Ucrania bolodimir selenski que pidió
nuevamente acelerar el proceso de
incorporación de Ucrania a la otan y a
la Unión Europea del otro lado del
frente de batalla el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin amenazó con graves
consecuencias si occidentes restringe
los precios del petróleo ruso que está
intentando entonces occidente hacer Está
tratando de frenar a Putin a través de
su producto de exportación más
importante el petróleo pues hoy en el
debate de France 24 nos actualizamos en
cuanto a la guerra en Ucrania porque
justamente se cumplen ya nueve meses
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa a el
territorio ucraniano para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a Zaira vadillo ella
es analista internacional es
historiadora enfocada en temas de Rusia
y de la unión soviética Zaira también
estudia los procesos políticos del
espacio possoviético en particular en
Asia central y en el cáucaso se conecta
desde la ciudad de Londres en el Reino
Unido y desde Madrid en España se une
esta conversación Fernando cocho él es
analista de inteligencia Y seguridad
internacional ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de esta
conversación ustedes ya lo saben pueden
dejar sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook y en instagram nos
encuentran como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate f24 no olviden también y ya para
terminar que todos nuestros contenidos
están disponibles en diferentes
plataformas de podcast no se encuentran
en Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y
en TuneIn
Bueno pues lo doy la bienvenida entonces
a Zaira en la ciudad de Londres
Buenas noches Zaira Gracias por estar
con nosotros Bienvenida al programa y
comienzo preguntándole por uno de los
hechos destacados de la semana
Comencemos hablando por esos bombardeos
a diferentes puntos de infraestructura
crítica en Ucrania que están afectando
hospitales vías de comunicación puentes
y por supuesto la infraestructura
eléctrica Cómo entender estas ataques
rusos una respuesta simplemente por el
retroceso En gerson cuál es el análisis
que usted hace
Me parece que la estrategia ahora mismo
de Vladimir Putin es un poco proyectarse
entre el pueblo ruso como que está
ganando terreno en alguna alguna área no
Y estos ataques han sido muy efectivos y
se han utilizado mucho como propaganda
en los medios rusos para dar entender de
que Ucrania pues no tiene la capacidad
de enfrentar a Rusia Sí si no tiene si
no tiene energía eléctrica no Y también
da a entender que da entender el pueblo
ruso digamos que más bien Esto es una
estrategia mediática también obviamente
sí tiene una repercusiones bien fuertes
en el campo de batalla porque está
congelando todo el país el invierno El
crudo invierno todavía no ha llegado
está apenas empezando y Esto va a tener
también una presión bien fuerte sobre
selinsky y también sobre el bloque
occidental que lo apoya porque va a
necesitar más dinero para reparar esta
infraestructura e infraestructura
energética con mayor rapidez pero me
parece que todo este ataque de misiles
las últimas semanas a las ciudades
principales a la
infraestructura energética también es
una forma de contrarrestar toda las
pérdidas de territorio que ha tenido
Putin en los últimos en el último mes
pero está haciendo muy efectivo porque
sí está destruyendo una estructura
infraestructura que es una
infraestructura muy vieja anticuada que
no va a ser tan fácil de reparar no Y
obviamente está ejerciendo mucha presión
además que en el pueblo ucraniano es
cierto que hay cierta unidad en ciertos
grupos pero también empieza a haber
cierto cuestionamiento hasta hasta el
punto de hasta cuándo vamos a sostener
esta guerra Y hasta qué punto vamos a
empezar algún tipo de negociación no
tanto entre los grupos ucranianos
digamos una presión de parte del bloque
occidental pero yo creo que esta
estrategia de parte de utilizar este
ataque de misiles también es parte de su
estrategia mediática de proyectar los
rusos que no no están en todas las áreas
del campo de batalla
pasemos ahora a preguntarle a Fernando
qué piensas sobre estos bombardeos
recientes estas intensas jornadas en las
que el ejército ucraniano ha tenido que
responder Ha logrado derribar algunos de
estos misiles sobre todo en la ciudad de
kiev y en pero han sido muy intensas las
jornadas de los últimos días en cuanto a
la operación militar Y sobre todo están
siendo días muy difíciles para los
ucranianos sin electricidad sin agua y
sin calefacción
Buenas noches desde España coincido con
en parte con lo que dice nuestra
compañera A ver vamos a ver la
estrategia militar rusa que su doctrina
militar Establece que la Infantería es
lo menos importante y que la base está
en la artillería en el lanzamiento de
misiles en la capacidad que se tenga de
destruir fracturas críticas sobre todo
en esta época de invierno Cuando alguien
ha hablado de que es Putin ha perdido
territorio desde el punto de vista
militar que es cierto no olvidemos que
dar en 2014 estableció que su cordón de
sanitarios gordo de seguridad era el
dombas fundamentalmente donexit y Luke
Garden para eso es lo que ha establecido
es una mala estructura primera logística
lo cual es el perder mucha Infantería y
mucho al momento pero pronto la parte se
ha reservado para ahora para el invierno
lo más importante de lo que es la
infraestructura militar rusa que son los
misiles los drones ya sean
iraníes o no no importa y las armas
digamos con mayor capacidad de
destrucción de fracturas críticas en
este caso misiles las continentales y
por supuesto los drones es lo que está
ocurriendo Pues que Putin sigue la
doctrina que ya estableció stalin en la
ciudad de Guerra Mundial que le llamó el
general invierno es decir llevar a las
ejércitos al límites capacidades de
resistencia logística en el momento de
la estación invernal que es lo que está
haciendo actualmente por tanto perder
para él 50 60 70.000 hombres o perder un
territorio aproximado de lo que es la
mitad de Gran Bretaña que es lo que es
el dombas no tiene importancia pero
tiene importancia es la infraestructura
final y la capacidad final que tiene
tanto Celeste como Putin de responder en
este caso Putin lleva horas de ganar
pero todo porque tiene un maletín
nuclear Fernando continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda la inversa y le quiero
preguntar por esta estrategia Rusia es
tal vez uno de los pocos países que
puede darse el lujo de tener esta
estrategia militar de el frío y el
hambre como arma de guerra Qué tan
efectiva puede ser en el contexto en el
que estamos
y qué tan certera puede ser para Rusia
esta estrategia teniendo en cuenta el
costo humanitario que esto va a
representar y lo que le va a representar
a Rusia en cuanto a a
muertes de ucranianos que luego se los
van a cobrar en en el escenario
internacional se lo van a reclamar y
nuestra razón pero son eslavos y el en
estos momentos que insisto es
probablemente Aunque suene raro es de
los más moderados dentro del kremlin hay
gente captado por doctrinas mucho más
duras desde el punto de vista militar
pues lo que está haciendo evidentemente
es lo que ya hizo Rusia con Napoleón lo
que hizo
stalin en el mundial con Hitler es
llegar al invierno y parar cualquier
ejército en es lo que llama el general
invierno el club de invierno el cual
ellos sí saben combatir y por otro lado
occidente no sabía A lo mejor ayudar con
diferentes infraestructura a Ucrania
como de Ucrania están en límites
capacidades técnicas en el límites
capacidades humanas no de moral no de
capacidad de resistencia moral sino
asistencia militar Europa Estados Unidos
ya ha dicho está bien de darle armas
incluso venderle armas y que lleven
llegar a una negociación por
intermediación de China y de India que
esto le implique a Putin convertirse en
un asesino o convertirse en un individuo
para el resto de la historia como un
asesino en masa y alguien que figure los
libros de historia como como Hitler le
importa bien poco es lo que le importa
es su doctrina interior su publicidad
interior y sigue manteniendo el poder
Europa y Estados Unidos
hacia china que es el gran vencedor y
perderemos todo contacto con Rusia en el
sentido durante muchos muchos años bueno
Rusia misma también ha sido víctima de
esta arma de frío y hambre para matar a
la población recordemos el sitio de
leningrado cuando los nazis cercaron
esta ciudad y la sometieron al hambre y
al frío durante muchísimos meses cientos
de personas murieron allí debido al
aislamiento al que fueron sometidos
dejamos este aspecto histórico que nos
sirve de contexto y para entender cómo
se está jugando la guerra allí en
Ucrania con este tipo de estrategias que
no son de ahora no son nuevas las hemos
visto en diferentes escenarios pero le
preguntó a Zaira por esa advertencia que
hace la ONU de una posible catástrofe
humanitaria a raíz de este uso de el
frío del hambre como un armamento de la
guerra estamos entonces ante un
escenario donde vamos a ver a los países
del este de Europa recibiendo otra vez a
ucranianos que de hecho muchos habían
regresado durante el verano y la
primavera Para apoyar a las fuerzas para
reencontrarse con sus familias y ahora
ante este escenario tan complicado que
se les viene para el invierno volveremos
a ver masas de ucranianos abandonando el
país
a mí me parece que es la única opción
que muchos de ellos tienen inclusive el
gobierno de Silence y hace unos meses le
pidió a muchos de los ucranianos que
habían buscado refugio temporalmente en
Europa que no que no regresara no porque
veía venir esta crisis energética que se
iba a suscitar por la cantidad de
misiles y en los ataques en
infraestructura de parte no obstante hay
países alrededor verdad Digamos como
Polonia la misma moldova y otros países
de lo que era antes parte del Pacto de
parsó Varsovia no de Europa del este lo
que estaba bajo El dominio comunista
muchos de estos países y los países de
Báltico Cabe destacar están recibiendo
gran cantidad de ucranianos que se han
integrado muy bien a esta ciudad hasta a
esta sociedad de donde ya tienen ciertos
lazos donde hay cierta complicidad en el
sentido de que guardan verdad una
postura política en contra de la en
contra de lo que está sucediendo en
Rusia en contra de
régimen de Putin Así que sí vamos a
volver a ver uno le afiliada muy grande
de refugiados ucranianos en estas en
esta región de Europa del Este me parece
que ahí es importante que que la Unión
Europea se concentre en darle los
recursos necesarios para atender lo que
lo que vamos a ver como una crisis
humanitaria mayor ya en Ucrania la
situación va a ser mucho más complicada
No todo va a depender de la rapidez en
la cual la asistencia humanitaria y la
rapidez en que se pueda al menos
temporalmente reparar cierta de esta
infraestructura pero sí es una crisis
humanitaria me parece que es la única
estrategia militar que está siendo
efectiva de parte de Putin yo Aunque
estoy muy de acuerdo en lo que mencionan
en términos de la importancia de tener
en consideración la historia verdad la
historia militar de lo que fue la unión
soviética a mí me gustaría señalar que
el ejército de hoy en Rusia no es el
mismo ejército que tenía stalin y
tampoco los ejércitos de la época
zarista no esto es un ejército muy
desmoralizado un ejército muy corrupto
un ejército que no tiene un equipo
militar moderno que un equipo
antiquísimo que parecen piezas
históricas para museos y no ha tenido
efectividad como tal vez
Digamos como los generales durante la
época de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
tuvieron mejores estrategias a pesar de
que tuvieran muchas pérdidas no hay que
establecer Esa diferencia no el ejército
de hoy ruso no es el ejército soviético
en estrategia militar han cometido
muchísimo muchísimos errores tampoco
tienen el capital económico para
modernizarlo ni la tecnología no
básicamente Rusia y computadoras de
manufactura pero volviendo a la crisis
humanitaria sí esto es una crisis
humanitaria que va a tener un efecto
bien fuerte en Europa y creo que si no
se atiende de una forma correcta puede
ser mucho mayor de lo que pensamos claro
es que si miramos la historia es Zaira
los éxitos recientes del ejército ruso
no nos vayamos tan atrás Afganistán fue
un gran fracaso para el ejército
soviético en su momento pero qué balance
puede hacer usted de las dos guerras de
chechenia y de la invasión a geo eso no
no son suficientes para levantar la
moral de las tropas rusas Bueno pero
esas guerras tomaron mucho tiempo en
ganarse la guerra de chechenia hasta que
se pelearon dos guerras una del 96 que
fracasaron y luego la del 99 del 2001
que básicamente para ganar limpiaron
todo Cross no para ganar la guerra
simplemente más eliminaron todo y luego
nos organizan también vemos lo mismo no
una falta de estrategia un colapso
económico que afectó a las fuerzas
armadas no y bueno
volvemos Georgia también fue una guerra
bien complicada verdad por la situación
de los territorios de
al sur tenías todas milicias locales que
tenían mejor estrategia tal vez que que
los rusos pero tuvieron el apoyo militar
un poco lo que sucede en Ucrania del
lado de ese linsky Verdad que es el
linsky tiene Tus fuerzas armadas pero
tiene el apoyo indirecto y directo
militar y de inteligencia norteamericana
del otro lado Me parece que que a
excepción de
las fuerzas armadas rusas no están
operando con mucha ayuda local fuera de
esas áreas no así que no no quiero
menospreciar el ejército completamente
pero hay que tomar eso en consideración
un ejército ruso no es el mismo ejército
soviético del de los 40 no Claro claro
Fernando retomó la comunicación con
usted y le preguntó justamente por la
estrategia que se puede gestar a lo
largo del Invierno puede ser un momento
para que los operativos militares se
reduzcan en buena medida y esto le
permita Entonces a las tropas ucranianas
rearmarse recibir muchísima más ayuda ya
veíamos a Estados Unidos el día de hoy
anunciando el envío de más ayuda militar
a Ucrania por cerca de 4 millones de
dólares que es el último banco de ayuda
que envía desde Washington es el momento
para que las tropas ucranianas se
realmen se reorganizan se reagrupen o
cómo estratégicamente pueden ellos
aprovechar el invierno y este momento
de la falta de de combustible la falta
de energía y la falta de calefacción
Cómo aprovechar la oportunidad a su
favor
Bueno aquí hay tres narrativas una
narrativa la de Estados Unidos que
cuatro millones de dólares se aporta
como último acción militar otoño de
dólares en una guerra de esas
características no es absolutamente nada
es poco más de media docena de misiles
antitanque o de de capacidades de
artillería no olvidemos que toda la
estrategia militar de punto de vista de
inteligencia Y de punto de vista de
operaciones y de comunicaciones la
sostiene Estados Unidos o sostiene Gran
Bretaña básicamente y la otan Si no si
no sin esto no podía haber ganado tanto
territorio durante capacidad militar de
Rusia Porque si bien dice una compañera
editor ruso es un geito exceptuando
algunas áreas algunas divisiones y
algunas partes de las fuerzas armadas
que son muy modernas las otras son
milicia de reemplazo y Carmen de cañón
con suele decir en el ejército no le
importa perderlo de todas maneras a
Putin nos encontramos que la única
estrategia es la segunda narrativa es
decir llegar a un acuerdo de negociación
que ya Rusia y Estados Unidos hace una
semana y media ya están negociando
intermediación de China llegar a un
acuerdo alto al fuego no olvidemos que
esos son de doctrina militar totalmente
clausevich es decir guerreo Guerrero y
peleo y peleo y mato hasta el último
momento que eso no impide la mesa de
negociación es decir Ucrania y Rusia por
conducto indirecto Ya llevan negociando
varios meses para conseguir parar esta
matanza y este este crimen de esa
humanidad no en este caso la tercera
narrativa es que Rusia evidentemente va
a rearmarse todo lo que es la frontera
la impermeabilización de la frontera
endoganes que es lo que realmente dones
perdón pero lo que realmente le
importaba de 2014 Según dice los
informes de la oste de hecho Putin el
año 2014 avisó Únicamente lo que iba a
hacer el año 2022 y los políticos
escucharon esa lista de inteligencia Y
de seguridad todo el mundo sabía que la
inteligencia que no sabemos el mes pero
sí sabemos el año que iba a haber una
guerra entre Rusia incorporándose por
medio del lombas a Ucrania y por tanto
ahora Putin se directamente
impermeabilizando esa frontera la gira
directamente hacia Asia de tal manera
que nosotros Europa caeremos en las
manos de lo que se llama la atmósfera Es
decir de la presión por parte de Estados
Unidos aliados para de nuevo ser un
territorio de avance económico para
ellos no olvidemos que la
infraestructura energética la dependemos
de ellos y evitar también y por tanto al
final tenéis que u obtiene el peso
específico de toda la otan o nos
encontraremos una guerra de trincheras
con la Primera Guerra Mundial justamente
yo estoy que menciona a la otan ni a la
Unión Europea también esta semana el
presidente selenski volvió a hacer este
llamado a la comunidad internacional ese
pedido acelerar la incorporación de
Ucrania a estos dos a estos dos
organismos a la Unión Europea y a la
votan Esto no se puede hacer de la noche
a la mañana claramente
qué tan posible es una incorporación de
Ucrania alguno de estos dos bloques el
militar o el bloque pues económico de la
Unión Europea en el corto mediano o
largo plazo Fernando imposible imposible
imposible
uno de los presupuestos básicos de la
otan es que ningún territorio que se
inquere incorporar a la otan no puede
tener ningún conflicto armado dentro de
sus fronteras y del año 2014 y antes hay
un conflicto armado lavado de guerrillas
como quiero llamarlo de guerra en los
vas por tanto ya no cumple el primer
precepto segundo para poder incorporarse
a la otra necesita el nivel económico y
de infraestructuras militares que no se
tienen o por lo menos una subsidialidad
de esas infractores militares algún otro
miembro de la otan cosa que se tiene os
juro por ejemplo en Turquía que si la
tiene y tercer punto para incorporarse a
la Unión Europea que no puede hacerse de
esta manera tiene que tener un nivel
económico y un nivel de
defensa derechos humanos que la obvia
ONU y la ha dicho que Ucrania No
ahora sino antes de la guerra no cumplía
por tanto por más que zelenski desde el
punto de vista narrativa que yo alabo y
comprendo y está muy bien hecha diga que
quiere incorporarse a la otra no puede
legalmente Sí incorporas a la Unión
Europea tampoco puede Zaira también
importante analizar lo que vemos a lo
largo de esta semana en las reacciones
en la Unión Europea a estos reclamos por
parte de kiev a las acciones de los
últimos días que genera también incluso
diferencias y discrepancias al interior
de la Unión Europea vemos a un bloque
muy decidido ayudar a Francia a Alemania
Polonia muy decididos ayudar a Ucrania
pero vemos a Hungría que se ha
convertido Por decirlo de alguna forma
una piedra en el zapato para la Unión
Europea para tomar decisiones en cuanto
a sanciones contra Rusia a la hora de
permitir la incorporación en la otan de
Finlandia y Suecia Hungría se ha
convertido en un gran
obstáculo para Ucrania digámoslo así
bueno Hungría y Urban me parece el
apellido Víctor Urban lleva ya hace unos
años
siendo la piedra en el zapato de la
Unión Europea y hasta cierto punto sus
relaciones están cercanas con con
Vladimir Putin también sus discursos
hasta cierto punto un poco fascistas tu
nacionalismo Me parece que ya
Hungría se veía venir como un problema
en crear un
como digamos un bloque a favor de apoyar
Ucrania y lo hemos visto desde un
principio Aunque en ocasiones ha
preferido estar no emitir comentarios
sobre al principio no cuando no hubo la
primera invasión pero también tenemos
que ver que lo que son los países de
Europa del este la misma Polonia que
ahora mismo juega un papel fundamental
en relación a los refugiados que vienen
de Ucrania también es problemática en lo
que tiene que ver con los Derechos
Humanos así que
digamos que por un lado en relación a lo
que estaba hablando el compañero
anteriormente sobre el
Ucrania querer ser parte de lotan y
también pedir ser parte de la Unión
Europea por parte de un discurso de
mantener vivo no
ser parte de este bloque y proyectarse
como presidente pero también
Creo que se pueden dar una
conversaciones a otros tipos de
asociaciones en los cuales se le se le
dé cierto cierta prioridad a Ucrania en
estos bloques en otras materias pero sí
Hungría es es problemático también lo
espolonia y en otras ocasiones otros
países de Europa del este no han tenido
es decir en la Unión Europea sabemos que
es un lugar muy
no y tienen sus distintos intereses y
sus distintas estrategias Me parece que
fue ayer que Boris Johnson empezó a
hablar sobre las conversaciones privadas
que se tuvo entre los distintos
dignatarios europeos han durante la
Guerra de Ucrania el primer la primera
semana y por un lado hablaba de que
Italia pues no quería tener ningún
no quería afectarse económicamente por
otro lado Alemania Pues quería que esta
guerra se acabará rápido y pensaba que y
pensaba que Vladimir Putin iba a ganar
fácilmente y por otro lado Francia Pues
tampoco se quería involucrar no así que
vemos que desde un principio las
narrativas han ido cambiando ahí
distintos intereses entre los países
pero indudablemente Hungría es un
problema también lo ha sido Polonia en
el pasado y mire también fue Turquía en
el caso de permitir a Suecia y Finlandia
ser parte de olotan y hay una
negociaciones no unas concesiones que
tal vez van a permitir que finalmente
Finlandia y Suecia sean parte del otán
yo creo que en el corazón de la Unión
Europea y de otan hay muchas
negociaciones pero hay una narrativa
única Como sucede a veces en Estados
Unidos que es representada por el
presidente actualmente No claro yo no
puedo entender algunos de los intereses
del gobierno en budapest del gobierno
húngaro y son esas comunidades húngaras
que justamente esas minorías que hay a
lo largo de la frontera como un con
Ucrania en el oeste de Ucrania hay
muchas comunidades húngaras que pues
están allí en medio del conflicto
también es parte del interés que pueda
tener budapest en torno a este conflicto
en Ucrania paso a preguntarle a Zaira
por esa declaración del parlamento
europeo de considerar a Rusia como un
país un estado promotor del terrorismo
esto en la práctica que alcance tiene
honestamente no tiene tanto alcance es
simbólico no pueden ejercer ningún tipo
de digamos embargo
económico o no pueden por ejemplo ahora
mismo algunos países tienen una
restricción en las visas de turistas a
rusos de rusos por ejemplo de los países
del Báltico y me parece que Polonia
también Esto es algo que no se puede
tomar a nivel el de la Unión Europea y
esta digamos más bien que esto es pues
un gesto simbólico Pero también es un
gesto para dar a entender al pueblo
ucraniano que su lucha no está perdida
que no cae en oídos sordos que que hay
un apoyo no pero esto no va a llegar a
mayores es Como sucede a veces con
muchas de las resoluciones de las
Naciones Unidas que no son vinculantes
no no estamos hablando de los embargos
que impone a los Estados Unidos cuando
declara ciertos países este
colaboradores de grupos terroristas el
caso más bueno que más conocemos en
Latinoamérica es el caso de cu que ha
estado bajo un embargo también Siria
Corea del Norte Esto no es lo que lo que
sucedió esta semana en la Unión Europea
es un gesto simbólico donde se le pide a
las a los Estados individuales tratar de
desarrollar algunas algunas políticas no
para para para que tenga un impacto no
pero claro es más bien
Fernando pasó a preguntarle ahora por lo
que podemos ver por parte de Rusia en
cuanto a la estrategia militar para los
próximos meses ya hemos hablado esta
estrategia del frío del Invierno pero
hemos visto que Rusia ha dado pasos
hacia adelante y luego da algunos pasos
hacia atrás el último caso el más
reciente es en la región de gerson un
punto clave en la costa del sur de
Ucrania y un punto clave para el acceso
a la Península de crimea este territorio
que Rusia anexó a la federación cuál
puede ser el siguiente paso de Rusia
recuperar jerson seguir por la actividad
a través de la costa del mar Negro o
intentar llegar aquí F del Norte
aprovechando Las bajas temperaturas cuál
cree usted que puede ser el movimiento
bueno todo el mundo sabe en la comunidad
internacional que la sesión que no
conquista por parte de gerson de Ucrania
fue una negociación que se hizo para que
se cambiara lo que el ministro de
defensa exterior es un cráneo y ha dicho
es decir Singer son No no es recuperado
no poder negociación y a la semana se
extendió serger son es decir en la
oscuridad y en las sombras está
negociando desde hace mucho tiempo por
parte de Rusia y Ucrania por países
Interpuesto por tanto estamos
presenciando una gran escenificación la
doctrina militar rusa o no cualquiera
Establece que hay que fortalecer las
infraestructuras que tengas en tu poder
básicamente los lugares muy difícil que
nadie a no ser Estados Unidos o la otan
recupere crimea sea o lo que sea que
tenga gerson y no olvidemos que Odessa
si en el lugar de Ucrania el poder de
Ucrania no porque estado Rusia pudiera
conquistarla sino porque se negoció una
salida al mar de Ucrania para la
exportación de sus cereales que por
cierto es China la segunda Mayor
compradora Mayor inversorales de Ucrania
por tanto los que no le beneficia a esto
es evidentemente a China y a Estados
Unidos por otra por otra bien directa en
cuanto a las sanciones que pueda recibir
el punto de vista militar etcétera pues
no solo tiene ningún tipo de fundamento
sino que no lo está haciendo la ONU
básicamente porque Rusia tiene poder de
Beto en el Consejo de Seguridad de la
ONU es quien de verdad ejerce poder en
la ONU y no las demás que son como ha
dicho la compañera muy bien son nada más
que
sugerencias de recomendaciones Y es que
nos damos cuenta de que Estados Unidos
es la que establece las sanciones
unilateralmente con países que llama y
en muchos casos tiene razón sean
terroristas tenemos el caso de Irán que
negociaría Turquía con Europa sin ningún
tipo de problema tratandose sobre
negociaciones Tenemos muchos países que
han sido nombrados supuestos grupos
terro
y no olvidemos que la milicia Zoo por
ejemplo hasta el año 2020 era
considerada grupo terrorista por Estados
Unidos hasta que pasó a ser su aliada en
la lucha contra Putin en el Barça por
tanto Aquí vemos un poco de hipocresía
la doctrina militar es fortalecer los
posiciones cada uno tiene en este caso
Ucrania terminalizará muchísimo apoyo de
la otan explícito que no va a tener
y por otro lado Rusia te quedará dónde
está No olvidemos que Rusia puede un
ejército muy malo pero tiene más de
5.600 casas nucleares Con eso es
suficiente sí Y ese es el temor que hay
a nivel internacional que saque alguna
de las cabezas nucleares que tienen ese
Arsenal Ya voy llegando al último bloque
del programa Quiero preguntarle a
Fernando y a Zaira por la posibilidad de
los diálogos comienzo con Fernando
porque en dos de sus intervenciones ha
hablado justamente de las negociaciones
que hay tanto públicamente como bajo de
Cuerda bajo la mesa que se está
negociando qué están conversando kiev y
Moscú en este momento Qué se sabe que
los medios no hemos reportado o que los
medios de esos dos países no han salido
a decir y que se está negociando
bueno se está negociando por varias vías
evidentemente no todo se cumple no todos
exige el mismo el mismo Rango no está
negociando una oposición
una una una idea que podía ser factible
de generar una línea fronteriza al
Oriente del niepe y al este del nieper
como frontera natural en donde se
quedaría algo parecido a distancias a
una Corea del Norte Corea del Sur con
atención militar constante pero al fin y
al cabo con una paz un armisticio
armisticio más que paz porque no había
una guerra declarada como tal en el que
se establezcan una frontera idílica en
el que no haya conflictos vale Y en el
futuro volvemos a negociar con Rusia por
su gas por su petróleo etcétera o sea
Europa de por sí Es hipócrita y toda la
compañía en el caso de
Turquía Turquía acepta aceptar en la
entrada de Finlandia y de Suecia en la
otan a cambio de que ellos quebrantando
su Constitución ten a refugia políticos
kurdos al servicio inteligencia
de Turquía por tanto hasta ese punto Es
hipócrita Europa la segunda línea de
negociación es que Europa se convierta
en un territorio de digamos así de
intermediación política para que tanto
Rusia como Ucrania Ucrania con un
estatuto especial de convenio económico
al que Putin nunca se ha negado y por
tanto el compromiso También militar de
proteger la frontera de Ucrania de una
manera indirecta Esa es la segunda
opción la tercera opción es que cada uno
llegue hasta el poder de lo que es capaz
de hacer lo veremos en la primavera con
el deshielo y dependiendo del apoyo que
tengan cada uno de ellos o las
estrategias militares que implanten
básicamente Rusia va a fortalecerse en
el almacenamiento de misiles de drones
gama chacales infraestructuras una y
otra vez
algo muy importante la compañía ha dicho
y tiene razón que el grito de a pie ruso
es casi decimonónico Pero porque ha
invertido en armas de mayor capacidad
nuclear o destrucción a Costa de la del
armamento tradicional misiles
hipersónicos el bure Smith los avantgar
el visitantes etcétera por tanto cuidado
con ese tipo armamento que con una solo
misil puede destruir casi la mitad de
Ucrania cuidado con eso y la última
Perdón
la cuarta negociación es que una tercera
vía Rusia India básicamente establezca
las normas de negociación en su
territorio bueno isaira que tiene para
decir sobre este tema de la negociación
y también los organismos internacionales
que podrían entrar allí la Unión Europea
la organización de Naciones Unidas y
Turquía que ha jugado un papel de
negociador un poco difícil de entender a
qué es lo que está jugando Turquía en
este conflicto pero pero se ha mostrado
Incluso como se ve para algunos de los
diálogos y Turquía Yo creo que es uno de
los grandes ganadores en todo este
conflicto además de China Claro está que
es el perfila como una potencia
económica
bien grande en este siglo pero ahora no
solamente eso sino que es Rusia va a
empezar a depender de China para su
sobrevivencia Así que digamos que son
como dos ganadores en términos a todas
estas negociaciones que se dan tras
bastidores se hablan muchísimo hay
distintas
Digamos como distintas formas en que
este conflicto pudiese llegar a un fin
pero no sé yo soy un poco escéptica no
porque tal vez soy de las personas que
no pensaba que esta guerra iba a ser tan
larga que que Vladimir Putin iba a
declararle la guerra de tal forma
Ucrania y y por un lado lo que me
gustaría subrayar aquí es que Rusia es
que muchas de estas ciudades que Rusia
anexó a veces son ciudades semifantasmas
mucha gente se También tenemos que ver
lo que pasa en Rusia como tal las
sanciones Sí están teniendo poco a poco
un efecto en la población estamos
empezando a ver distintos discursos
también dentro de la Elite rusa un poco
lo que lo que voy a esto es que yo no
creo que a pesar de que hay cierta
negociaciones y se hacen ciertos
cálculos y y se hipótesis yo creo que en
el lado de lo que es federación rusa
cuando uno empieza a ver el Injusto que
hay en relación a esta guerra y las
divisiones que están que hay en el seno
del poder Pues habría que pensarse quién
está negociando no poner un fin que va
que va a ceder
así que yo no estoy tan segura de que
esta guerra sin antes de la primavera
Creo que todavía en la primavera vamos a
ver el apoyo que tienen cada uno de
ellos pero yo creo que hay que notar
también en la sociedad Rusia sí está
sufriendo las consecuencias está
empezando a sufrir
Pues creo que ninguno tenía como cálculo
que esta guerra se fuera a prolongar
tanto justo estamos haciendo este
análisis porque se cumplen ya nueve
meses del inicio de la invasión rusa al
territorio del Don vas y esto pues
continúa Seguiremos analizando aquí en
francés 24 los hechos que vayan
ocurriendo en los próximos días Le
agradezco asadera de Fernando por haber
hecho el análisis para la audiencia de
France 24 en América Latina sobre estos
hechos recientes es todo por el momento
el nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Giovanni
agudelo y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera siga con
nosotros
[Música]